[Korean] Hello. I'm hui jing who loves css the most. Nice to meet you! Unfortunately, I am not good at Korean, so I will give a talk in English.
Translator in the back. Thank you
uh that that is my name in hanja I'm not sure
how it sounds in Korean but I'm guessing uh
the pronunciation is a bit different I'm not
a complicated person so these emojis pretty
much cover who I am as a person I also have a day
job with Shopify as a senior front-end developer
because I like being able to pay my rent and stuff
um so today's talk is focused on CSS because if
your content is going to be rendered by a browser
engine then your main mode of communication with
the browser for styling content has to be CSS
Now browser engines today are much more capable
than before and they can lay out content much
better than before so it is in our best interest
as web developers to know how to make full use
of the browser's web layout capabilities now a
major issue with web content is that your users
could be using a screen as small as a smart watch
face or as large as a 70 inch HDTV and you as the
developer or the designer or the Creator you can't
control this which means that the way that we
think about designing layouts on the web cannot be
like anything else that is fixed it is a different
mental model and the tools that we use must suit
this fluid interactive medium but luckily for
us now that flexbox and grid are well supported
across all the major browsers our toolbox has been
greatly upgraded because both these layout models
were introduced after the web had evolved into
more than just a document viewer they were built
to handle application interfaces which would
be viewed across many different screen sizes
now admittedly flexbox had a relatively Rocky
rollout as browsers implemented experimental
versions of the syntax before the specification
had been nailed down but by 2015 the major
browsers had updated to use the latest spec and
the implementation was very stable so the browser
vendors and specification authors they learned
from the flexbox rollout and developed grid behind
the feature flag instead of using vendor prefixes
so grid was rolled out in a very coordinated
manner in 2017 with the four major browsers
getting it in March and by October even Edge and
Samsung internet got it so when we fast forward
today 2022 the percentage of Internet users
surfing the web with browsers that support flexbox
and grit is overwhelmingly High way past 98 so
browser support is no longer a valid argument for
why adoption rates I feel are lower than expected
honestly flexbox is everywhere because it has
become the go-to for web layouts I've seen my
thousandth how to center something vertically
with flexbox articles so I'm not surprised that
it's so common today but even though this survey
is a relatively small about 8 000 developers it's
still prompted me to wonder why the grid usage
numbers are not as high as I expected now among
the 13 links I have in my bookmarks bar I could
only find grid usage in codepen Discord inbox and
Spotify and only Spotify really Embrace grid as
a page layout tool they even use named grid areas
JavaScript was introduced in 95. and a few
years later the concept of Ajax which stands
for asynchronous JavaScript and XML started to
take off because it allowed content to be updated
dynamically without reloading the entire page
and this is what single page applications or spas
are built upon that's the concept but the term
single page feels very misleading because the
single page of a book doesn't feel very large but
if you think about a lot of the Spas out there
today it's more like a page the size of this
room so it's like Spa and with this increase
in scale and hence complexity the organization
of code becomes a lot more crucial so we turn to
Frameworks because Frameworks can help provide
structure but with Frameworks there are some
restrictions on how to do things so maybe that's
another reason why grid is not so common but first
let's do a quick run through of how grit works
and how to use it very similar to flexbox it
involves apparent child relationship between a
container and its immediate children so if you
apply grid properties on the container you will
affect your individual grid children and the grid
children themselves have an awareness of their
siblings now the bare minimum to start using
grid as a layout tool is to set display to grid
and then you define some columns so for example
two columns three columns you theoretically don't
even need to be explicit about the rows unless you
want to because the row height will naturally
be what the content is now if your grid needs
to be a little bit more complicated grid comes
with a lot of helpful functions and properties
to keep your code neat so for example the grid
property is a very straightforward way for you
to introduce spaces between your grid items there
are also things like the repeat function that can
help you dry out your code for example if I
don't want to type that four times I can do
something like this because it repeats patterns
um another helpful feature would be keywords for
example if we use autofit in combination with
another function like the min max function I see
um you can actually do responsive
design without media queries
so if this is something that fits your
use case you don't actually have to
do media queries to do something like
this with the help of these functions
but another particularly useful feature which I'm
a big fan of is named grid areas which you might
have noticed in the Spotify screenshot earlier so
after you've set up your rows and your columns you
can actually name specific areas of the grid you
can assign them names the syntax is quite visual
so the structure of the grid template areas
property is a reflection of your grid so each
of these three lines corresponds to three rows
on your layout and each of the values within the
lines are the two columns so I tend to make use
of this for designs that need to break at multiple
breakpoints because then all your changes can be
isolated on the parent container so what you do
is that you can assign your items to specific
areas like SSI the m is contents and you don't
have to touch it anymore so let's say I uh I
don't I want more columns I want to add column
to this layout so let's let's change some things
around maybe make that 200 so now I have a three
column grid and I need to move some stuff around
right so how about let's make the header full with
the side okay I
spell wrongly the okay it's come on
so what this what this shows is that if you have
many different layouts that you need to have at
different breakpoints you can isolate them all on
the parent container because this is very simple
there are only four grid items but let's say you
have a more complicated layout maybe you have
20 items you don't want to have to write media
queries like four media queries for each of these
items it becomes very hard to maintain so I feel
that this is pretty helpful for keeping the code
very neat and very easy to manage moving forward
but naming grid areas is actually an optional
property I just find it useful the regular way
of placing items is to Define its grid row and
grid column properties so I'm going to try turning
on the grid inspector so you can see uh all so I'm
using Firefox but all the browsers like Chrome and
Safari all have this overlay so what you can do is
you inspect the element and you can turn on this
grid overlay and it will show you grid numbers
so my image starts from column number one it
spans two columns my headline starts from column
number two and it spans until column number
four so that's how you place items right and
an advantage of something like this is that it
makes overlapping design much more controllable
than any other methods like if you try absolute
positioning transforms negative margins it's very
hard to control especially across different
different sizes but the code I have set up
here I have the middle column where the image
and the header is overlapped to be always 300
pixels so what happens at different widths
is that I have a controlled overlap I feel
that what this does is that it makes the lay
out a lot more resilient at the very extreme
risk like at the largest and at the smallest
width it's a lot more resilient with less code
so there's a lot more to grit than I just
explained but this is already sufficient
for a very large range of ux cases and the major
difference in building layouts with grid versus
other layout models is that CSS grid layouts are
led by the container so you implement your layout
using a big picture view of your entire grid and
then you place the items on the grid but the other
layout models are focused on the item so you have
to size and you position your item individually
and so it's it's very different from what
a lot of folks are used to so maybe that's
also a contributing factor to why grid is not
as widespread that being said it's not like you
have to use grit for everything no grid is just
one more additional tool that you can use flex
floats are actually still great and relevant
for floating content okay and flexbox is great
for handling free space in your layout and grid is
perfect when you need structured rows and columns
but as an application grows bigger and has more
features more components and more pages you end
up having to adopt some sort of a design system or
develop some sort of design guidelines to maintain
consistency across the application so often you
have a grid system and a common pattern for grid
systems in front-end libraries like bootstrap
is you generate all the classes that you need
for all the with potential risk that you have
for the sizing of each item in your grid so this
is not even the full the full is I don't know four
thousand lines right and to migrate from floats to
flexbox is actually not that drastic a refactor
because your sizing still happens on the item
but to migrate to grid is a lot more complicated
so for the sake of discussion we'll simplify it
we'll have assume that we have the luxury of
implementing a new design system no refactoring
and we want to build out the grid system for
that so let's say your designer hands you
these specs that your designers like build me
this grid with your code your CSS or whatever
there are many different approaches you can
take to write the CSS to implement this Grid
in a JavaScript powered application so we'll
go through a couple of these examples to give
you an idea I'm using react in the examples but
the ideas are transferable to other Frameworks
as well so one option is to just write the CSS
so most applications have a global style sheet
you can put yours you can put the grid Styles
there the rationale is that because this grid
is meant to inform where everything on your
application would sit it can live in the
global style Street gets loaded everywhere and
so you would if I use something like a Min width
focused breakpoints it will look like that you
start off with four and then you bump up as in
in each breakpoint as you require and then your
item placement code where you want your items to
be can go into the component itself so if they're
common placement patterns that recurve very often
in your design you as the person in charge of
the front end component Library you can have
pre-written styles optional but not necessary
so you can do something like this pre-written
Styles and then the people who use your system
can use these Styles or they can write their own
so if you're very custom placement the code
would go into your component specific styles
another approach would be if you have you
could create container and item components
so this means that your grid code is not loaded
in the global style sheet but it's tied to these
components so if you want to use it you have to
call these components so the setup is you want
to create a column component a grid component
and then these components are very lightweight
they're thin components they don't do a lot
because all they need to do is be a grid right
so you have things like okay custom class names
you can modify the element tag because honestly
I know Ria defaults to div but there are a lot
more better HTML tags out there so like please
use them and but in general these are very
lightweight so not a lot of lines and they're
not they don't restrict you from doing custom
things because all they need to do is be a grid
so the Styles would end up being the same as
in option one because uh but if you're using
something like this you probably use something
like CSS module so you're naming convention for
the classes can be a bit more casual because
option one had to use bam for for the classes
but with something like CSS modules you know
you can worry less about the class names and
then your custom code can go into your component
styles uh well I'll I will be upfront about this
I am not the biggest fan of how Tailwind does
CSS the major issue I have with Tailwind is that
it sees the Cascade as a problem to be solved
rather than an attribute to be embraced
but if you use Tailwind the way it was intended
the Cascade is almost negated it's gone
but it's called cascading style sheets c s s for
a version so my suggestion is for them to Rebrand
to Tailwind SS just cut out the sea that being
said I'm not overly stubborn about this if my
job needs me to write Tailwind I can still do
it the way it was intended because capitalism
but for now I accept the reality that there are
quite a number of teams that use Tailwind CSS in
their applications and it's working very well for
them so that's great so if those teams want to use
CSS Grid in their application it's totally doable
because Tailwind has exposed almost every API
for you to modify the default config to suit your
custom specs so the grid specification that we saw
earlier can be set up something like this it's a
little bit more complicated but yes you can do it
all right and then you would have to apply these
classes to your components accordingly so maybe
there's some way to make it less ugly but this
is the most basic version and it will be able
to achieve the exact same result as the previous
two options so okay this is the butt does it work
so all the code that I showed you is not fake
code it's a real code because I I tested it
um so it kind of it works uh let's inspect just
to show you that I'm not bullshitting um layout
so we can see that all the approaches that I
discussed um like grid areas grid template rows
it will work for a very I would say sometimes
your designers will tell you things right like
I want something to spend five columns or
like seven columns and it's not even an
even number but you can you can do this
relatively straightforwardly using grid
and the the thing is that even the Tailwind
example that I kind of made fun a little bit of
it looks exactly the same the only
thing is you probably won't be able
to use the named grit areas but the point
the point of this example is to show that
all three approaches can achieve exactly the same
result right which brings me to my next point
we cover only three options but there are a lot
more possible approaches to implement the grid
that we just talked about is any of these one
approaches the best are they the correct one
I cannot answer that question because you can't
answer that question without taking into account
the context in which your code is going to be used
technically as I've shown every approach does the
job perfectly so usually the the difficulty in
technical implementation is lower then when you
need to consider things around code organization
maintainability and developer experience
especially for larger teams because every
organization is different some applications have
individual teams in charge of specific components
other team other organizations could have a few
front-end Specialists maintaining a component
Library used by everybody so the permutations are
endless and Company culture also varies between
organizations right in some teams Engineers have
a lot of autonomy they can make decisions they
can decide I want to use this I want to use that
in others it's a bit more top down so sometimes
a director who used to code will come in and
tell the team you must use x technology because
I like it such things are out of your control
and that's okay but if you do get the chance
to influence technical decisions I find that
asking the following questions can help you make
a more informed choice that benefits the team in
the long term for example what are the preferred
Technologies used in your organization if any
usually there is one it's public knowledge that
Shopify is a Ruby on Rails shop so it's not like
we refuse to use anything else there are projects
that don't use Ruby on Rails but we do need a good
reason to deviate from the stack so from a CSS
perspective because we use rails this is going to
impact where my my CSS code lives it will impact
whether you use a process preprocessor or not how
your selectors look like how much control over the
mockup you have and so on the size and structure
of your application will also have a significant
impact on how it's organized and how your final
CSS will look like and live how flexible does your
design system need to be because the more flexible
it is the more complicated your code might
end up becoming because you have to cater for
more use cases so this is where having a closer
relationship with the design team can help because
even though a design system starts out from the
design team is like a deliverable from the design
team the success of the design system hinges on
the code reflecting what was originally intended
is are there a lot of new developers
contributing to your Project's code
and what's the documentation culture like
because these two are related because if they're
constantly new people onboarded to the code base
you need solid documentation to explain what the
expectations are and how things work otherwise the
code is going to become very messy very quickly
maintenance it's not the most exciting thing
in the world but systems work because someone
is maintaining them and keeping them humming
along so who who are these people for your team
is it a centralized setup spread across different
teams what is the skill level of the people on
those teams like how good are they at the tech
stack all this needs to be taken account into
what you choose for your approach so my suggestion
for decision making is to not look at the pros or
advantages of each approach because all of
them have them rather you should analyze the
cons analyze the disadvantages to determine which
ones you and your team can accept and live with
and after you've taken all this time to figure out
the approach there's one more very critical thing
to do before diving into the fun part of writing
the code and you have to document the why because
if you are not part of the team who built the
application from the start they're going to be
parts of the code base that find you seem weird
or like it's odd why is this done this way and
instead of being judgmental I strongly suggest
asking why why were things done in this way
sometimes you might find that it was really
just a bad idea right someone put something up
there because they had a deadline or they didn't
know how to do it better but sometimes you will
also discover that there are some constraints
some or some dependencies or just a particular
situation at that time that was not obvious to you
because you were new to the code base on the team
so I know some people don't really want
to update documentation you always hear
comments like oh our application is so fast it's
so fast that the documentation that I write today
is obsolete tomorrow that's because it's how
documentation why documentation is different
a paper trail that explains why the way things
are is like whiskey it only gets better with time
so is it possible to use CSS Grid in a large
commercial application from a technical
perspective absolutely yes but is there a best
way to implement it well there'll definitely
be a best way for your team to implement it which
will probably be different from the best way that
my team does it because of all these factors that
we've just discussed so if you ever get the chance
to implement CSS Grid in your project I want to
repeat what hung said yesterday is that we would
love to hear you share your experience if you
can because even though your approach is specific
to your situation it might still Inspire someone
else who is working on theirs it comes on my diet